sept ans d'attentes pour en arriver à ce
procès aux assises de saône et loire
la famille et les proches de jacques
vote sont venus nombreux ils espèrent
enfin avoir des réponses au meurtre de
cet homme de 74 ans 4 octobre 2013
jacques vaude et sa compagne sont
agressés pendant la nuit à leur domicile
d'autun l'homme décède
sa compagne est grièvement blessé et
victime d'agression sexuelle une famille
dévastée par ces faits terribles puisque
je défends les ans pendant que leur père
a été tué d'une manière sauvage
dans son lit la nuit c'est donc terrible
et voilà d'abord de cela avec évidemment
ils sont satisfaits d'en arriver là mais
c'est très compliqué pour eux pendant
plusieurs mois les rumeurs se
multiplient l'enquêté piétine
c'est un mouchoir abandonné qui met les
enquêteurs sur la piste de l'aig shicoff
l'adn de ce ressortissant bulgare et
retrouver un kilomètre du domicile des
deux victimes incarcérées dans son pays
d'origine
il purge une peine de 10 ans pour un vol
avec violence ce mode opératoire
rappelle aux enquêteurs l'agression au
domicile de jacques vaude il a
effectivement une personnalité très
inquiétante
décrite par certains comme voilà
quelqu'un de très violents on a
effectivement des faits en bulgarie qui
sont assez ressemblant de ceux qui lui
sont reprochés aujourd'hui sur le
territoire français en particulier ceux
commis à l'encontre de jacques baudot
malgré la présence d' adn proche de
celle d'oleg kickoff retrouver sur un
ordinateur de la compagne de jacques
vaude l'accusé nie toujours les faits
qui lui sont reprochés
il faut pouvoir effectivement un être
certain de la présence de l'adn de
l'accusé sur effectivement la souris
d'ordinateur ce qu il ne me semble pas
être le cas faute d'aveux ou de
témoignages celle expertises génétiques
qui va être ici déterminante
les parties civiles vont devoir
démontrer que les minces traces adn
retrouvées sur l'ordinateur de jacques
vaude sont bien celles de l'ecti kof